[Music]
let's begin
yeah this is going to be a pretty
serious game 1900 okay so we've been
playing e4 pretty exclusively
and we have been playing the four night
scotch
how it uh holds up at this level
and this game is no exception okay he
takes d4 knight takes d4 okay so even at
this level people still take on d4 which
as we've now discussed many times
is not a serious mistake but definitely
significantly inaccurate it gives white
ooh now b6 i think we've faced something
very similar before this is a really bad
move because black is not sensing that
stuff is about to go down in the center
we can go after black we we can go after
black
just with the movie five that i mean
that that should be an instinct for you
guys at this point if you've watched the
speedrun enough you know that the movie
five and the four knight scotch is is
incredibly strong in these types of
positions so bishop c5 this is what our
opponent was relying on but it's one
movitus right it's one move itis he
thinks oh i'm attacking the queen and
developing a piece so it's good but if
you calculate further the knight is
going to have a very hard time finding a
square now where should the queen go
well
here's the thing if we go back to d1 i
think that's a little bit passive and
that allows this with queen e7 pinning
the pawn and attacking the pawn i like
either queen h4 which is a nice square
out of the way of the other pieces or
my favorite square is actually the
square f4
and this might not be intuitive to you
if you're looking at this and saying how
do i really come up with this square
well okay
our opponent is showing us why we come
up with this score because now we drop
the queen back to f3 and this is in my
book called a fork okay this guy is
really bad i'm sorry but he's playing
really badly
okay he's like not even trying at all
this guy is not even trying at all we're
just gonna bring our queen back
yeah we're gonna play another game i
mean there's not much to talk about here
i i don't understand this at all queen
h4 but let's not let let's not you know
lose our discipline let's continue to
play accurately yeah he's making
superficial blitz moves so here i think
let's focus on the game though rather
than fooling around let's actually try
to be accurate so rather than you know
again what should be the approach here
should be to complete the development
because we still have not completed our
development and we need to try to castle
as quickly as we can now if you ask
yourself that question how do we castle
as quickly as we can to me it makes more
sense to castle queenside like we have
the option of castling queenside
especially because we have the potential
to play this move bishop e3
which contests black's only strong piece
which is the bishop on c5 and prepares
the castle queens it's simple strong and
winning
simple strong and winning so d6
yeah okay we can take on c5 we can
castle it really doesn't matter oh
castles maybe there's bishop g4 i guess
that's that's flexity let's start by
simplifying with takes okay so now we
just need to solve one small problem
which is that if we castle black has
this move bishop g4 pinning the queen to
the rope that by the way would not be
the end of the world we'd still be up a
piece so yeah artibia is suggesting a
move that i really like which is just to
play bishop e2 now remember in such
situations
your priority is to castle and complete
your development it doesn't really
matter
how actively you develop your pieces for
god's sake your upper rook so once all
of this is done you'll
you'll move the same pieces to more
active squares that doesn't matter what
matters is just to complete your
development okay so now we have a really
nice move here
uh which is which is this move queen to
e4 centralizing our queen and preparing
to simplify further with bishop takes h5
and offering a queen trade yeah a3 was
also possible we could have chased the
queen away with a3 but i like this move
more because okay well now we obviously
take the queen
we can go knight t5 and we can win
yeah this wasn't a very serious game
unfortunately
okay so now let's stick our knight on f6
and one quick way that we can try to win
this is just by pushing the the kingside
pawns because we have a majority okay we
have two plans that i see the first is
the double on the d file we can play
like rook d2 rook d1 and rook d8 but you
know what move is super classy there's a
super classy move that we can make here
it completely restricts black stein if
you watch tess enough
you will know that hess likes these
kinds of moves look at this knight
knight for a second it can go out to f5
so we play the move g4 we restrict this
knight and you should be familiar with
this setup the fact of the pawn being
two squares being between the pawn and
the knight and they being in the same
file
and now rather than dilly dallying let's
stick our rook on d6 go rook d1 rook d8
and win the game yeah yeah this is this
is
rook d1
and rook d8 is unstoppable
yeah diamond pawns that's true
oh we lost the pawn yeah oh damn i think
we should really yeah
dammit i missed the eyes yeah no this is
there's no hope continuing
the game now
we lost our a2 pawn i don't know how we
can continue functioning without that
pawn really yeah we can't we lost we
lost the apon i mean that that just
honestly
you know we might have to hold a funeral
for it
by the way here folks just remember this
mating net after king g7 we would have
gone g5
in order to set up rook g8
okay i'm sorry very underwhelming game
but maybe we'll get a better one next
time so a couple of pointers
and you can learn from every game i
think one thing i want to make clear to
you guys is that you know if you if your
time is limited then you need to put
every minute that you spend on chess to
good use and part of that in my opinion
is to to squeeze the juice out of every
single game no matter how bad or good
the game was there's usually some lesson
that you can extract from it something
that you can reaffirm
some concept that maybe you already know
but that you review which is it's always
good to review the stuff you already
know
and i think here the concept is first of
all that people don't know how to play
against the four knight scotch even at
this level
once you take on d4 black is best
advised to play d6 here i mean you have
to stop e5
but our opponent succumbed to one move
itis he thought oh i get the bishop out
with tempo
the thing is that doesn't matter queen
f4 is i think a really nice move and you
basically use process of elimination to
decide where to put the queen okay
so i don't like queen d1 because of this
move queen to e7 attacking the pawn
hopefully that makes sense
i for the same reason i don't like the
moves queen d3 or queen c4 so we we need
a move that keeps contact with this pawn
and for the same reason i don't like
queen h4 because black has queen e7 and
somehow black is kind of getting out
here
does that make sense
after queen f4 if black plays queen e7
our hands are untied
our pawn is no longer hanging now the
pawn is still pinned but we can easily
unpin the pawn with bishop e2
the knight has to move back which is a
disaster because now r knight leaps into
d5 and the rest is
you know just a huge initiative so queen
f4 i think is a is a pretty subtle move
and it's nice
okay then we go back to f3 now whenever
you take this rook on a8 you always have
to be a little bit careful because i'm
sure you guys are aware
that there are variations where the
queen on aid gets trapped i'm sure you
know such lines where you take a rook in
the corner and then your opponent sets
up
you know something like this
and then is able to trap the queen i'm
sure this is a concept you're familiar
with so but but obviously here
the black is nowhere close to this and i
think a lot of beginners are afraid to
take the pawn on b7 or to take the rook
in the corner because they fear that
their queen is going to get trapped but
you can't just be afraid of something
without calculating it and and
concretizing it and here concretely
there is nothing
so
but but still you shouldn't play with
fire i mean if you're given the
opportunity you should get your queen
back
and we don't really care about this pawn
i'm happy to lose this pawn
okay so bishop b3 castling queenside
prioritizing completion of development
and then using the threat of
simplification to essentially make
improvements to your position trading
queens sticking the knight on an outpost
restricting our opponent's knight and
then doubling on the only open file and
delivering checkmate on the eighth rank
easy
lemon squeezy
questions about this game what's bad
about queen d1 queen e7 queenie two asks
dr lord
nothing queen e2 is great actually no
this is probably good too yeah somehow i
didn't see queenie two to be honest with
you queenie two is good it's a little
bit awkward because it blocks the bishop
but it also forces knight i agree with
you
although i would say that yeah because
the queen blocks the bishop
you can do this but wouldn't you love to
be able to go bishop c4 here and attack
f7 right here you have to waste
another tempo moving your queen out of
the way
and going like queen e3 white is much
better i'm not disputing that white is
not much better white is much better but
i think with the queen being on f4 you
can do this in one fell swoop yeah so in
the vienna gambit in the vienna gambit
this is what you're referring to if you
play the vienna you should know this
line
where e takes f4 which is a big mistake
but a lot of beginners play this the
move is d5 here by the way
after ef4 one of the first things i
taught my student who plays the vienna
is this line queen e7 now you play queen
e2 and that forces the knight back to g8
you develop your knight to f3 in order
to prevent the check on h4
and a lot of people lose the game
immediately here with d6 who might push
plays knight d5 and it's but you're
busted the queen has to come back and
now if you want to be really sexy
take on c7 first
before taking on d6 both moves win on
the spot
because after queen c7 ed wins the queen
so this is a nice trap in the vienna
that you should be aware of
okay we have another black game so maybe
artie
will get his wish no okay so so we'll
play the queen's gamba decline structure
which i promise to do we'll play queen's
gamut declined which is e6 of course and
one of the good things about being a
queen's gamma decline player is that you
don't really need to study the english
that's a huge huge benefit right it's it
just cuts the amount of work you have to
do because you can play e6 and white has
ways of avoiding the queen's gamma
decline but not many of them most of the
time you find english players end up
going d4
why can the only yeah so white plays
this
uh in the sort of traditional english
manner this is really the only way of
doing that there's a high probability of
transposition to the catalan so if white
plays d4 at any moment now we get a
catalan if white plays this with b3 then
we get a more traditional english
reverse bononi structure but again white
takes on d5 prematurely this is a bad
move this releases the central tension
it gives us a better control of the
center and it's completely and totally
toothless so i feel like people at this
level who play this stuff still aren't
fully
you know still don't fully comprehend
the reason behind
this opening d4 okay so
we need to figure out how to position
our minor pieces and there is not one
correct answer here there is multiple
ways of developing but i am very partial
i'm very partial to putting this bishop
on d6 i like putting it on d6 and then
following up sort of london system style
with the move c6 just like we did in the
previous game now we don't need to play
c6 immediately we can castle first let's
castle first it doesn't really matter
what order you do things in here this
isn't a night or if this isn't a sharp
opening you can do stuff in many many
different new orders
and now i like the move c6 just look at
how nice this looks c65 we've got a
bishop in the middle there
now where should the light squirt bishop
go start thinking about that and should
it stay on c8 maybe we should go knight
bd7
and if it should develop where should it
go f5 g4 e6
which square are you partial to
well if you're a london system player
then you should already be biased toward
f5 yeah bishop f5 is where we want to
put it right prevents it with queen c2
okay that's not a problem
now
we have a certain we have a pretty
radical move we can play g6
and prepare bishop f5 but obviously
obviously g6 is very weakening
especially because we're not
fianchettoed on g6
so bishop g6 is interesting i don't
think it's a terrible move
but here's my proposal let's start by
playing a very flexible move let's see
how white positions his pieces and then
we will decide
how we
you know what we do so what's an example
of a flexible move a move that we know
for a fact is going to be helpful is
rookie 8 we know that this move is not
going to hurt us how do we know that
well the wreckage is good on e8 we're
also preventing knight to e5 which in
some situations
followed by f4 is quite annoying
now i want to show you guys a very
typical maneuver
that uh
allows us to get this bishop onto this
diagonal without playing g6 which i
really don't want to play
so we first play bishop g4 and then we
swing the bishop around
from h5 and we don't need to do this
immediately the bishop is quite happy on
g4 but white has played h3 we dropped
the bishop back and then
we're really happy if we can get it to
g6 does that make sense that is an idea
i'm sure that some of you have seen
before i will show you an example of
something very very similar in a
classical alakine game afterwards
but also remember that we can
stay on h5 for a while we don't need to
automatically go bishop g6 immediately
in fact we're not going to we're going
to stay flexible here what should we do
now i'm sure that some of you are
tempted to play h6 here
which is a completely fine move but
i would not like to uh take on f6 with
the queen i would like the queen to be
able to access the other side of the
board if necessary so let's go knight
bd7 as
we have planned
and on the next move we
might very
seriously consider the move h6 so white
plays a3
now
it is quite clear that white is
preparing to expand on the queen side of
b4
that is not a particularly scary idea
given how white has positioned his
pieces so i'm going to make an
interesting point to you guys i
99 of people here would play a5
automatically
but what i want to show you is that you
can allow b4 in these types of positions
and then play the move a6 and freeze
that pawn in place and it's actually not
not that great for white so we're going
to ignore that idea entirely and we're
going to play the move h6
forcing this bishop to decide
i'm anticipating bishop takes f6 okay
bishop b3 is a blunder
why is it a blunder this is a common
idea
i can't tell you how much this is missed
so the bishop on e3 what can you tell me
about it
well any contact between two pieces is
something i've told you to notice
if you notice this contact you say well
what is defending the bishop oh it's the
pawn on f2 what else is the pawn on f2
defending ah it's defending the g3 pawn
it is overloaded
it's overloaded
now
white has a counter desperado with
bishop takes h6 i am hoping that our
opponent plays it because we have a very
instructive response to that move
hopefully the logic makes sense okay he
takes unfortunately i'll show this after
the game we take on e3
we are in fantastic shape here
our next move is very likely to be queen
d8 to e7 in order to increase our
control of the
default but oh actually we have a better
move i think so rather than going to e7
right rather than going to e7 where else
can we go with the queen what else
exists what are the other options
yeah i think queen c7
i think queen c7 is a nice looking move
because we're hitting white where it
hurts on g3 and we are preparing to
double rooks with rook 8 to e8
well now we're definitely going to
double rooks actually wait a second
if we want to end the game we would play
bishop g6 here
if we want to try to end the game
quickly but we're going to play rook a8
instead we're going to we're going to
take this slow
because the reason i was saying bishop
g6 is a tricky move is because queen d2
would have blundered okay
whoa
oh my lines there's some cool stuff
going on here wait a second
oh i think it's time for tactics ladies
and gentlemen
i think that time has come
actually maybe maybe we can just drop
the rook back to e7 there are
interesting tactics here
but i'm not totally convinced that
it's worth going for them
and i'm going to be super annoying
because yeah i'm look i'm thinking about
94 chuck
the problem with 94 check is not that
white takes the rook on e3 that's
winning i i admit that that's winning
thank you i need a drink
the problem with 94 check is that white
goes king g1
and then somehow the rook on e3 is
actually trapped
so
it's not so easy there to to prove full
compensation for the exchange and it's
not necessary
but but what is the point of the speeder
and the point of the speedrun is to show
you
how i would play in these situations and
i've said this before i will say it
again
if you want to be a sacrificial
attacking player
i think the biggest hallmark of people
like tall
you know and morphe those players is
that they know when to play it simple
right they know in which situations just
to play a simple move and win the game
without adventures and wrap it up
because if you're always going for the
brilliancy prize and you're always going
for the cool moves then you're going to
leave a lot of points on the table
through unnecessary sacrifices
and moves that you know you shouldn't be
playing look at this this is so much
easier just queen takes g3
and uh
this is game over
i mean that's the second pawn we have a
rook lift to g6 coming up
okay now we have a winning sequence we
have a two move sequence that wins the
game immediately who can find it
who can find it
it's very simple i mean it's just boom
boom
which is boom boom
very good true masternode
so it's all about order of operations
here
yeah we can do it in either order but
the best order is to play knight takes
f2 first
and then after rook takes f3 to play
bishop takes f3
um it's actually quite a bit more
accurate than bishop takes f3 which a
lot of you guys were suggesting
because i'll show this after the game
this is less accurate this is more
accurate the game is over because white
cannot capture the bishop
in any of the three ways this is illegal
this blunders the rook and this wonders
the rook
okay now let's finish right off let's
not give white any
breathing room at all
and if you want to do that then what is
the most decisive move here
what is the most decisive move let's go
rook takes c2
rook takes e2 is crushing because if
white plays rook takes f3 you say well
white counter-attacking the queen don't
forget the bishop on g2 is going to be
hanging with checkmate we take on e2 and
we win the game
easy
easy easy easy and very passive play by
white
very very very passive i don't know who
recommended this repertoire to white but
it's not a good one
so c4 e6
so white decided to start by playing
this like in english
now once again
d4 in this position would lead us into a
catalan
and i would say the catalan is like
super unpopular below 22 2300.
it's not that you can't study it if
you're like 16 1700 but i wouldn't
recommend it to anybody under 2200
really
because of how complex it is because of
how much theory there is you have to be
okay playing down a pawn for long
periods of time
which is not an easy skill so i wouldn't
really recommend the catalan to anybody
um
okay c takes d5 is just really bad if
white wants to play this like in english
the way to do that is to play bishop g2
now black can take on c4 in any of these
positions and that's a legitimate
sideline the most popular move is to
play this like a queen's gamma decline
bishop e7 castles castle now again d4 is
the catalan but b3 is like the
traditional english way of playing it
and in this position black has a
gazillion moves you can play this like a
benoni with d4
and then you get a benoni structure e3
c5 i played this with white
you can play this more sort of queen's
gambity with c5 you can play the move a5
which was pretty popular until recently
i mean there's a ton of moves here even
b6 is very solid like a queen's indian
this is about equal but it's a very
interesting you can play this line this
line is this line is cool
uh but but cd5 is is totally toothless
it's it's
it yields the center it gives our bishop
the chance to develop
and white is just slightly worse here
probably if anything
so bishop g2 castles castles we play c6
i hope that this setup makes sense
um a lot of beginners tend to play
knight c6 in these positions and this
stems from a lack of understanding of
the
sort of positional properties
of of this line or of d4 openings in
general because you have to keep the d5
pawn under lock and key if you play
knight c6 in these types of positions
what tends to happen
is that white plays knight c3
and then white plays bishop g5 and
you're already experiencing problems
with the d5 pawn by the way the same
exact thing
goes for the karo khan when when you're
a beginner
a lot of beginners what they do against
the karo khan is they play knight c3
super super common i've even had some
students
who play this who are not or not
beginners
and this is bad for exactly the same
reason the pawn on d4 becomes a serious
weakness because you can't defend it
because you've blocked the c pawn and
black has the ways and means to attack
that pawn queen b6
bishop g4 in response to knight f3 that
knight on c3 is neither here nor there
so it's very important across many
different openings not to block your c
pawn in general that's why we played c6
now last thing i want to say is that
why are a lot of newer players worried
about putting a pawn on c6 because i
think the way that some players are
taught they're taught that unless you
develop your knights to f3 and c3 and c6
and f6 that somehow you're making a
concession
that somehow developing the knight on d7
is automatically passive and that could
not be further from the truth and as you
get a little bit stronger you have to
start approaching development with a lot
more flexibility so the move c6 is kind
of a no-brainer
queen c2 rookie 8 so we just decide to
play flexibly knight c3 and now bishop
g4 and on this topic
i would like to show you guys a
interesting application of this exact
concept
okay so we have karpov kasparov
from their 1985 match
and in this position i i really like
what kasparov does here it's like a
super high level positional concept
let's flip the board so gary starts with
this move that i think a lot of people
wouldn't play
he he plays his move a5
and it's a very annoying move to face
because if you allow black to expand on
the queen side with a four
well that's annoying right you're you're
not going to have as much real estate on
the queen side to operate
so karpov goes a4 but what is
the drawback of this movable the
drawback of this move is that it weakens
the b4 square and you stick a bishop
there so these kinds of ideas like
pushing a pawn forward to grab some
space and provoke a weakness very
important right but after king e2 this
is the reason why i'm showing you this
position in the first place
i'll give you a chance to think
what did kasparov do in this position
what maneuver oh there's a moth what
maneuver did he come up with one second
let me try to kill this moth
goodbye
okay what did he do what did he do
yeah so he plays so he plays bishop g4
check
f3 and bishop h5 same exact idea as in
my game
three bishop h5
and uh yeah conquerors are so hard to so
hard to bring down it's crazy
like you just smash it and it just still
lives
castles
and then bishop g6 and the point of this
move
is to trade white's only active piece
which is the light squared bishop and
without the light squared bishop
white is stuck with this really awkward
piece and this really awkward piece
and his whole position is just entirely
discombobulated
so
i just thought this was
similar
just this concept of maneuvering this
bishop around to g6
is uh something to consider when you
cannot access this diagonal directly
if that makes sense
okay
when you cannot access this diagonal
directly
yeah all of this for structure and for
squares i mean that's just
the nature of what you do so that's kind
of what we did here we go bishop h5 now
we don't go bishop g6 immediately
we we chill but we have this thread the
thread is strong in the execution so now
we go h6 and bishop e3 is just really
really underwhelming now uh
okay well if bishop takes f6 knight f6
and b4
what i wanted to point out is that just
because your opponent has played this
move doesn't necessarily mean anything
you just play a6
you just play a6 and
white can never really play a4
white can't even go rook b1 because of
bishop g6
so if anything b4 creates a major hole
on c4
if that makes sense how bad is it to
push g6 to prepare the bishop movement
said well not bad i was talking about
that during the game i didn't want to
play g6 here
because i was worried about bishop g5 i
this seemed annoying to me
and you could argue a bishop f5 queen b3
is what was annoying in particular
because now you can't play queen b6
because the knight is gonna hang this is
exactly what i was trying to avoid with
the move g6 so that's why we came up
with this idea of circumventing it okay
so bishop e3 is obviously a blunder we
take g3
and i was really hoping that white would
play this move because i think it
affords us an opportunity to play
something very instructive
now most of you are probably looking at
this and saying okay bishop takes f2
check is what occurs to you
i
am quite confident of that
and then you play g take stage six but
don't stop there yes you have one upon
yes you've won upon but you've also
weakened your own king side and you've
given white the opportunity to double
rooks and now 95 becomes a problem
so this i would say is very unconvincing
for black
instead i think black is a really really
powerful move
essentially you have a couple of tempe
if you move your bishop back white is
gonna have to waste the tempo moving his
own bishop back
so
if you've decided to move your bishop
you should think about where you want to
move it
and for what reason you have eliminated
the pawn on g3 which is the important
fact
what clue does that give you if there's
no pot on g3
then this diagonal is now a serious
liability well what is the best way to
arrange pieces on a diagonal it is to
play bishop b8
so bishop all the way back in only there
and then queen c7 with the tremendous
threat of bishop takes f3 and quinn h2
check and this looks really really bad
for white
this is a super nice move bishop back to
b8
right using the absence of the g3 pawn
to build
a battery against the h2 square
i love retreating moves like that
they're so subtle and so nice
unfortunately our opponent just sort of
you know seated the game without much
resistance
but notice how we can how we act how we
uh converted our advantage right queen
c7 attacking the g3 pawn we're not
letting white breathe rook ae8
and then the main moment came here i was
really tempted by this move as well
now
94 check why is it tempting well it's a
rook sacrifice don't tell maria the 300
bits and i won't tell her promise
king takes e3
so this position is winning because
white's king is simply
i mean how do i describe the state of
white's king
there's no squares and if it goes to d3
you can drop your bishop you know what i
love is that we finally play bishop g6
here and we waited until the best
possible moment to do it when we have
the deadly skewer
pin discovery against white's queen on
the next move
now what's the problem
gumby with the bits let's go
the problem
the problem
is that
white plays this move king g1
white plays this move king g1
and all of a sudden the rook is trapped
if you look at it carefully the rook is
trapped now is black winning absolutely
what should black do here well probably
black should play knight takes g3
white plays knight takes c3
and now not knight takes f1 because of
knight takes f1 alaska chess with a five
holy smokes
but rook takes c3
and white plays rook f2 and black has
two pawns for the exchange and
overwhelmingly placed pieces but
why have we given up an exchange exactly
what has been the purpose of that other
than to look cool for a movie you see
what i'm saying now so rather than
engaging in all of that spaceship
trucker with the gift itself holy spa
anita with a with a sub we are not even
stopping here jesus
we just moved the rook back to e7 we
keep all of the advantages of the
position including the deadly threat of
94 check now white could have been more
resilient absolutely you know our
opponent could have maybe played g4 to
get the pawn out of g3 or maybe played
knight c3 here to to discourage knight
e4 oh my god
oh my lands girl
did i just see 5.069
from an anonymous cheer
who is this
what is going on
yeah don't tell me that's the shroom guy
again
yeah i know he's in the chat
oh my god
5.069
unbelievable
total giga chad but just to finish the
thought
um
what would we have done here well
probably we would go 94 check anyway
maybe oh and then d take c4 and e3 check
and e3 check is coming
so we are winning this way in that way
but this is a much simpler move this is
a much much simpler move
then we go knight e4 last thing i wanted
to discuss
why did i do queen takes g3 rather than
knight takes you three it doesn't matter
knight takes g3 is completely winning
two
but
after rook f2
my guess was that i would have to move
back to e4 anyway and i thought that the
queen on g3 is just a much better
attacker even though this move is not
technically with tempo
knight f2 oh and the last thing why
didn't i take on f3 first because move
order matters we know that thank you
anonymous thank you plongo
but after e takes f3 here if you play
knight takes f2
uh white can actually play queen takes
f2
and somehow white avoids losing a piece
some because the black queen is hanging
and if you take then white takes with
the king thank you elf matthews
okay black is completely winning here
obviously completely winning two puns up
but
in the other move order you actually win
a piece
in the other move order you actually win
a piece you take on f2
then you take on f3 and here you
actually win the piece
yeah
um okay rookie f1 and bang rook takes c2
not letting white breathe
pretty easy win i mean
where were the pivotal moments of this
game i think bishop g4 was a really good
decision by us to get this bishop around
to g6 instructive idea
right just because you can't get the
bishop on one square of the diagonal
doesn't mean that you can't get it onto
another and it also doesn't mean that
you shouldn't play g6 ever i can give
you scenarios where
this idea of going g3 bishop f4 or g6
bishop f5
is the only way that you should continue
but in this case you just have a
different way of doing this without
weakening your king side
yeah then bishop h5
then obviously our opponent blunders a
bishop e3
we notice tactics even in quiet
positions pawn is overloaded and the
rest of the game is easy
the dollar amount that shrooms ended was
was unbelievable micro popper 9487 give
me those primes give me those primes
holy smokes
okay um
and that's that
was c5 knight c6 too adventurous instead
of c6 in that position well let's take a
look arti bear is suggesting the move c5
well okay c5 i just don't like because
i don't like c5 because
i don't like this because you get an
isolated queen pawn position
and white's pieces you're essentially
justifying the placement of the bishop
is what i'm trying to say
you're justifying the placement of the
bishop which is now pressuring the spawn
and if you play d4 too early you don't
solve all of your problems because why
does this move knight a4 in these types
of positions
and you're just you're just
you've bitten off more than you can chew
in comparison to c6 i feel like
i would there is no compare if is c6
still go to white hasn't fianchettoed
light square bishop good question
the answer is yes
i mean if you're a queen's gambit
decline player you should know the
carlsbad structure
you should know
that in the carlsbad structure white
plays e3 bishop d3 yes and black still
plays c6 i mean this is just a pawn
chain right this is neither particularly
good but certainly not particularly bad
it's a nice pawn chain you know but but
in the carlsbad yeah you get you get
this pawn chain and you keep playing so
the answer is yes you definitely still
play c6 even if white doesn't fianchetto
but but just the concept of restricting
your opponent's pieces right very very
important using your pawns to shape to
shape the position
in your favor
something that i think a lot of players
struggle with even though it's actually
quite a simple concept
but this idea that you shouldn't be
afraid to use your pawns
to make your opponent's pieces
a lot more useless
than they are and i think an example
that i have shown before on stream
and that i will show again
is this stein this game this is where
classical games like games played 100
plus years ago are really really good
because they really have these ideas
uh in in pure form
because the games tended to be a lot
simpler if that makes sense
so you don't have as much fluff you have
you know you you have pretty clear
illustrations of a lot of these concepts
so this position steinitz is black
what do you guys think he played and he
made a very simple move here a simple
series of moves but still very
instructive
so he plays b6 yeah and and he does that
to restrict the knight
english plays h3 steinis drops the
bishop back and who can tell me how
steinitz followed up and this next move
is really the the instructive part of
the sequence yeah he goes c5 so look at
how he uses his pawns to take away
all of these key squares
from the knight and the bishop now you
might say okay great but where
what is that leading into
well what it what it's leading into and
stein spends a while just expanding a
little bit on the king side and he gets
the d file
and then he expands further
and then in this position
he carries out yet another instructive
idea
yet another instructive idea what idea
does he carry out you have fully
restricted your opponent's pieces now
it's time to make even further progress
and uh push white's pieces off the edge
yeah a5 a5 is is super super classic
this knight on b3 is gonna get pushed
away you can't play a4 because you drop
the knight so steinitz advances the pawn
to a4 he literally pushes right off the
board look at this position white can't
breathe and steinitz ends up winning the
game pretty quickly
and i'll show one other
one other example of something like this
from one of my games how you know
do i actually learn from
this kind of stuff well the answer is
yes
here's a game where i applied
a very similar idea
and an idea that dovetails also into
what we talk about
uh what we talked about through the lens
of
the game that i just played
so i drew this game ended in a draw but
that no matter
because that's not the point
this position in this in this position i
found an idea that i was really really
happy with during the game
i'll give you guys a chance to find it
black to play
so the position seems pretty colorless
it's an isolated queen pawn position but
clearly black's pieces are quite active
yeah so i played
okay not a6 yeah i played g6
my opponent castles and how did i follow
up like g6 is pretty obvious because you
restrict the knight but how did i follow
up
h5 h5 exactly h5
then i play h4
and actually if white had not gone b4
then i would have followed up with
bishop f5 and look how my pieces come
alive here like the position changes
completely so you send that pawn forward
and a lot of people when they look at
this they say i get the idea but i don't
understand how you know that you can
just weaken the king like this
so
the reason is that first of all g6 is
not a serious weakness you're not
actually weakening the king
all that much by playing these moves
right this misconception that pushing
puns in front of the king is bad yes it
usually is but it depends on how you
push those pawns
the second thing is that white has
absolutely no firepower to ever attack
the king side in the near future
now is it possible that at some point
black strategy will backfire that white
will somehow assemble
king side pieces
yeah absolutely but you can't play chess
like that you can't guarantee
safety from everything
you know what i'm saying
so
this is a classic idea one of my
favorites this concept of going g6 and
then shoving the g9 off the board with
h5h4
okay so a little bit of a detour there
but i hope you found that to be
somewhat enlightening
yeah the minority attack of course is a
very serious idea and it's one of the
main plans for white on the carlsbad but
in this specific game the minority
attack was not scary because white's
bishop was so misplaced
[Music]